Simplify the expression 28a to
the fourth, b to the sixth,
over 7a to the ninth b.
So a good place to start here
is to just try to kind of
break this up into things that
we can simplify a lot easier.
So the 28 and 7, we know that
28 is divisible by 7.
So let's say we break that apart
into 28 times-- 28 over
7-- times-- and then we can
break this one apart-- a to
the fourth over a
to the ninth.
So times a to the fourth
over a to the ninth.
I'm just rewriting what we did
here, but I'm writing it as a
product of three terms instead
of just one term over here.
And then finally, you have this
last term over here, b to
the sixth over b.
So times b to the
sixth over b.
And if you multiplied all this
out, you'd take the product of
the numerators, you'd
get that up there.
You get the product of the
denominators, you'd get this
right there.
The whole reason I did that is
because each of these terms
can be simplified
pretty easily.
This 28 over 7, that's easy.
28 divided by 7 is 4.
Then we have the
a to the fourth
divided by a to the ninth.
And when you have an exponent
in the denominator, you can
subtract it from the exponent
in the numerator.
We have the same base,
a, that's why I
grouped it this way.
So this is going to be equal to
a to the 4 minus 9 power.
What's 4 minus 9?
It's negative 5.
4a to the negative 5.
4 minus 9.
And the same thing here
with the b's.
Times b.
6 minus-- you have a 1 here.
You don't see the 1,
but it's there.
If you just have a b, that's
the same thing
as b to the 1 power.
So b to the sixth divided by b
to the 1 power is b to the
sixth minus 1, or b to
the fifth power.
And we're done.
We've simplified
the expression.
If you don't want a negative
exponent there, you could say,
well, this is the same thing
as 4 times 1 over a to the
fifth-- that's the same thing as
a to the negative 5; these
two things are the exact same
thing-- times b to the fifth.
And then this, of course, would
be equal to 4 b to the
fifth, a to the fifth.
Or you could put 4 b to the
fifth over a to the fifth.
All of these are legitimate
ways, but all of these are
simplified versions of our
original expression.